great thing so I'm gonna in this talk I
was trying to decide how to structure it
for this very diverse audience so I
decided to kind of follow the computer
science tradition of giving an overview
of a lot of papers I know that sometimes
a little frustrating to economist who
are used to going into a lot of detail
on a single paper but hopefully on the
upside at least you'll get a little bit
of a sense of why I've been working on a
collection of disparate topics and I
think it's really the spirit of market
design that you go into answer a
question and you have to bring in tools
from lots of different disciplines to
get the right answer and so you give me
to get a little sense today of why I'm
proving central limit theorems and doing
network theory and all sorts of other
crazy things all in sort of pursuit of a
goal so in my the co-authors on the work
I'm talking about today include Dennis
Mac couple of who's here hedo in bins
who worked on some of this work together
with me at MSR and he's now working at
Amazon part-time also Stefan bloggers a
graduating PhD student statistics
brilliant student and D knuckles just
move from facebook they up data science
to a faculty position at MIT so you know
we're all everybody here is excited I'm
sure about the recent advent of
marketplaces and auction based platforms
and nobody here needs more motivation
that market design matters in these
settings one of the particular type
places where the extra sort of oomph of
sort of theory and generally social
science tools is really important is
distinguishing things that have
different effects in the short run in
the long run so in some sense like you
know it's pretty easy for businesses to
make good market design decisions when
you do something and you see the effect
and the short one which is predictive of
the long run then like even if you don't
have any training at all you kind of
discover it you see it in a be tests and
short-term experiments and you kind of
don't screw it up all that often the
places where you can sort of massively
screw things up and send an organization
you know innovating in the wrong
direction for four years and that that
applies actually to all of the major
tech firms we all know and love they
have areas where they innovate in the
direction for years are the places where
the short term in the long term actually
give you opposite conclusions but it's
actually fairly common for especially
advertising marketplaces or e-commerce
market places where you have sellers and
buyers coming together so just to give a
bunch of examples you know I I had a
guest speaker who used to be a VP at
ebay who came in and get told a whole
bunch of these stories of how he somehow
use data to get ebay to do some of these
hard decisions but things like
eliminating with lifting fees or making
posting pictures free economists
understand immediately why that might be
a good idea but you're walking away from
a couple hundred million dollars in
revenue in each case so the short-term
looks very very very very bad and you
have to have the economics to put it
into the long-term things like changing
the search algorithm to empathize
emphasize price or for sellers into more
uniform categories emphasizing
prioritizing people of low shipping
costs and so on all of the all of these
are things that have different effects
in the short-term and the long-term
because the sellers respond the search
advertising examples are maybe less
obvious if you're not into the
nitty-gritty but but in some sense even
more insidious there's there's basically
like a very easy way to make a whole lot
of money in search advertising so you've
got all these advertisers who are
putting in ads and some of them are
putting in like one hundred dollars a
click first best those related queries
and thirty dollars a click for auto
insurance related queries and then
you've got like you know toothpaste
related queries that are worth like four
cents okay and you have all this big
database of advertisers and they've put
their bids in that database so if i
change my algorithms in a way that
accidentally or maybe accidentally on
purpose drops a few auto insurance
queries on to adds on to toothpaste
queries okay boom you've just made ten
million dollars 100 million dollars you
know you've made a billion dollars if
you're looking at the overall say google
search revenue and it looked beautiful
in a short term test if you just look at
revenue just taking those Auto Insurance
ads and putting them on toothpaste
queries it's going to make you a lot of
money now that's a
any economist cease immediately that
this is like not a long-term solution
for making a lot of money because of
course why well there's incentives the
auto insurance advertisers will notice
that they're not selling a lot of cars
on the toothpaste queries and so they
will lower their bids okay but it turns
out that actually measuring and
documenting that is super hard because
advertisers have true genius they
respond at different times things are
very noisy and so on so this is a this
is a problem that basically like
especially say when Yahoo was under
pressure before they shut down their
search engine they basically ran down
their quality month by month by month by
month over a period of three years until
their prices went down like thirty
percent because every month they just
make things a little bit worse they
cheat a little bit put a little bit of
those good those high value adds on to
low value queries the numbers look great
this month and you don't pay until next
month and if you're worried about
getting taken taken over if you're about
to quit all sorts of things you know you
do that and so that that group of people
actually got very very good at cheating
the system before under high pressure
from the management another example is
just changing pricey ok so again as an
economist you like the firt the whole
reason we study the whole theory of
auctions and mechanism design and so on
is all about like revenue equivalent
serums those are based on people
changing their bids and responding but
surprisingly enough the practice really
has a hard time taking all that into
account so of course a theoretical
framework is a key and so even though
I'm not doing that much micro theory
myself anymore I just want to really
emphasize that I've never stopped for
one moment being a believer in the huge
power of economic theory to understand
all these things because you need to you
need to have a very strong understanding
belief in conceptualization of what's
going on to understand why you walk away
from 200 million dollars of fees of
people posting pictures on eBay and so
on and some of the things will never be
really possible to fully measure and so
that belief in that conviction and the
and the theory and the experience all
plays a really important role but at the
same time you know these are very
data-driven businesses and so you do
need to try to bring data to bear on
these questions as much as possible
so you know how can data help in these
situations well data can inform what
kind of designs will work better or
worse in a range of environments similar
to the existing one fairly easily so if
I'm thinking about modest changes you
know if I'm thinking about changing
fonts or doing small things then i can
just very easily look at data and it'll
tell me about small changes the hard
part is when you're going to change the
world a lot and then you need to you
need a much more sophisticated analysis
so experimentation actually is this real
mixed bag so experimentation is you know
the way that all changes get made I'm
sure everybody here knows that there's
you know ten thousand experiments or so
run a year at Google everything that
changes the smallest change in the code
goes through a randomized controlled
experimentation process this is crucial
for the speedy innovation of all of
these high-tech firms because an intern
can propose a change put it through an
a/b testing platform if the numbers look
good it can ship immediately and that's
how you can make changes to your product
every single day in a highly
decentralized way so experimentation is
like the heart of rapid innovation but
people get seduced by it and end up you
miss using it and misunderstanding it
especially people who aren't really used
to thinking about economics and economic
theory so short-term experiments by
definition can't show long-term outcomes
and feedback effects and I'll show you
it's even worse than that in the
standard practice and all the major tech
firms you know has like like just really
idiotic flaws but that somehow remains
standard practice so you know so i'll
talk about advances and experimentation
that if they're sort of at the cutting
edge right now and fear in academics and
in practice another way that you can get
around it is to try to get insight by
analyzing heterogeneity of effects and
so that's a focus of my one focus of my
research another approach is to actually
use what's really the standard toolkit
of empirical economics which is to use
what we call structural analysis to
estimate people's underlying preferences
essentially calibrate the theory model
with data and once you have all the
parameters of the theoretical model you
can do counterfactuals you can say what
happens if i switch to a Vickrey auction
what happens if I
change prices and so on now the problem
I have with my first round of that that
I did within us is that we did great
unlike a small set of very high value
keywords where advertisers were super
rational and we're maximizing all the
time but we kind of flopped when we took
our model to the broader spectrum and so
the final paper I'll talk about today is
is work in progress we have where we
actually asked to use a Bayesian model
to estimate these these the preferences
of bitters and we have a much richer set
of objective functions of a measure so
the the we're going to tell you about
today basically then was going to fall
into a couple of categories advances in
the theory of experimentation advances
in machine learning and account of
bringing machine learning Taylor with
econometrics to estimate heterogeneity
effects and then finally kind of a
large-scale application in a large-scale
Bayesian model of the traditional sort
of economic approaches so we all know
about a/b tests randomized controlled
trials we're going to take users put
them into treatment and control groups
look at their outcomes and make use that
to to decide whether I ship a new
algorithm and the way that this is
commonly used like it you know amazon or
ebay or google would be that actually
the treatment is going to often a new
algorithm so there's like one algorithm
for ranking results and another
algorithm for ranking results and you're
going to test how those algorithms
perform so they're not like isolated
experiments where you're just changing
you know one little thing and figuring
it out your testing complex algorithms
which is one reason that people often
don't understand like when they
accidentally on purpose put up auto and
turns on toothpaste it's because they
tested like 50 algorithms but the one
that happened to put up auto insurance
on toothpaste by mistake it's going to
have the best revenue numbers and so
that's why you systematically innovate
in the wrong direction you're selecting
things that look good according to a set
of metrics so um just to see like
exactly why things are can be so bad in
the sense the standard industry practice
the easiest thing to do if you want to
test a new algorithm is that you put
take either a subset of users like you
track cookies and take the user
or you take a set of page views so the
same user as you do subsequent searches
might be in different groups so either
page we were user but it's it's a really
at the user level you're going to give
you know some users one algorithm and
some users another algorithm and then
you measure revenue and user experience
and you have maybe four or five key
numbers that you look at to the side if
you if this algorithm is an improvement
or not so it might be good for the user
experience you know a little bit bad for
revenue and you'll make trade-offs along
that line so there's multiple errors in
this if you're thinking about the
revenue number in particular the unit of
experimentation is not the unit of
analysis so if I'm experimenting on
users any particular seller on ebay or
seller on amazon or advertiser on google
will see only one percent or half
percent of their traffic in the
experiment so if I'm an advertiser
advertising on auto insurance and in one
percent of my traffic I'm getting some
ads put up on toothpaste all right I'm
not really going to notice that so even
even there so there's there's the issue
that it's often a short experiment but
even if it was a long experiment as the
advertiser I don't I can't I don't even
know I'm being experimented I don't know
how I'm being experimented on I might
just see a little noise in my data but I
certainly am NOT might the results of
this experiment are useless for the
counterfactual of what would happen if
you applied this algorithm to all of my
traffic so if I want to know what
happens to an advertiser if all of my
traffic sees my auto insurance ads put
on toothpaste queries this experiment
doesn't doesn't shed any light on that
whatsoever yet this is the standard
practice so what are all the other
mistakes well the interaction effects
between the bidders are then or less
ignored because the advertisers
themselves aren't being stimulated it
might be that if something like this if
it's some experiment you know increases
prices for an advertiser for all
advertisers some advertisers might hit
budget constraints then that's going to
affect the other advertisers so even
before you get to strategic
considerations you're going to see very
different outcomes when you release the
thing to the whole platform is when you
for a particular user then there's of
course the game theory part that they
actually might respond they might
respond just to their own situation and
they might interact with one another and
then it finally the thing that's
probably most important for marketplaces
as long-term participation and that's
totally ignored but yet we operate all
of these platforms in exactly this way
so i think the the e-commerce platforms
some can do a little bit better because
it's easier for them to segment their
market into product categories so there
is some history and and and and process
of experimentation like at the product
category level with the ebays and
amazon's it's actually much harder to do
for reasons i'll show you a minute in
search engines um the other thing people
sometimes do is New Zealand so you know
that basically like every platform you
know releases things first in New
Zealand and they see what happens so but
that's you don't have much of a control
group and so on when you do that so so
some of the cheaper fixes then this is
kind of you know a bit of the state of
the art that's motivated by theory but
makes still doesn't really slow down
your progress or change things
fundamentally is to modify the
evaluation criteria so for example when
I'm going to decide whether to ship a
ship an algorithm I've got some some
numbers i'm looking at and i might
measure revenue that seems like if
revenue is what I care about I should
measure revenue but if you're an
economist you realize that no you
shouldn't measure revenue because some
of that revenue is not sustainable
revenue it's not equal librium revenue
so the particularly the revenue from
putting the auto insurance ad on a
toothpaste query is misleading revenue
but I booked it in my my experiment but
it's a bad prediction of the
counterfactual of what would happen if I
shift it to the rest so one of the
things that I did early on it Microsoft
would suggest that you throw away money
that you made in a bad way and you don't
even count it when you when you evaluate
your experiments okay and so by by
measuring something that's not actually
what happened now but a better predictor
of the long-term you get a better answer
and you also diminish the incentives of
Engineers to try to test algorithms that
put auto insurance on toothpaste because
they know that they're not going to get
credit for that type of
so there's a lot of variants of that
another thing you can do is do a small
number of long-term studies to relate
short-term metrics to the long term but
this this has its own problems and it's
it's somewhat limited in scope and then
another thing you can do is adding
constraints that protect advertisers
like I know at Facebook there's these
suck rules so there's experiments that
you can't run there's not allowed to do
that and you might say you know in
search maybe I'm going to not i'm not
going to ship things that affect any
advertiser too badly like if you're
going to give some advertiser or three
hundred percent price increase go back
and fix it you put in rules or
restrictions and so there's a this is
one kind of heavy-handed way to to try
to keep things under control make sure
that you're not that you're not
predicting any that you're hurting any
of your sellers or advertisers too much
but this is also a very crude approach
so now I can get into the more expensive
solutions and the solute the solutions
where there's more of an active research
going on to try to get these to work
better so we want the first thing we
could do is we could actually experiment
the advertiser level so i could give
some advertisers a price increase and
others a price decrease now that's
actually much harder than it is that you
think because the advertisers are
actually competing in an auction so your
pricing mechanism not just setting
prices for people there's like a
marketplace and if you think about
what's happening on amazon or ebay you
know you're going to your what you're
doing is you might change a search
algorithm and that's you know if you put
one advert one seller up higher and
other sellers down lower so it's
actually like technically conceptually
sometimes hard to think about how do i
shock one seller without shocking
another seller because one better the
other worse you know one brighter the
other less bright so so there's some
tricky things about that but you can
imagine trying to do a smaller set of
them and finding them and look looking
at the graph and put trying to find
people who are isolated from one another
to do that that can be kind of tricky so
here's just some examples so suppose
you're on ebay and you shop for how to
train your dragon costume there's going
to be a certain set of so this is for my
daughter for Halloween there's going to
be a certain set of sellers that compete
for that query then I might look at
frozen costumes
and I'm going to have some kind of you
know sellers that sell princess stuff
and I'm going to have other kinds of
sellers who sell halloween costumes
competing on that query then I might go
to how to train your dragon toys and
there's going to be people competing on
that who's who sell how to train your
dragon stuff but also other stuff so
essentially you know ecommerce markets
or bipartite graphs where the degree of
competition one seller or advertiser has
with another is determined by which user
queries they compete on and of course
once you realize that you realize that
the whole graph is connected so there
really aren't any isolated sellers and
and so then you have to get into the
world of engineering I think it's
actually not surprising that some of the
early papers and network experimentation
were written by computer scientists like
Uganda and Kleinberg and so on because
they were maybe a little more willing to
make compromises than some kind of Trish
ins and so on who tend to be more
purists and kind of stopped when we
can't get the right answer but so one
paper I've written in this area is to
try to test interactions and so the
application this has applications for
general social graphs but the
application and e-commerce would be
maybe I can test the hypothesis that
people who were removed from each other
by a certain distance don't really
affect each other and then if I could if
I could reject the hypothesis that they
affect each other then I could actually
you know give me some guidance to how to
cut my graph and maybe I could safely
ignore some interactions so that's one
application of the theory this jitter
this paper is it really a statistics
paper and the question is how do you do
inference properly for various
hypotheses in a network setting where
everybody competes with everybody else
so let me just tell you briefly like
what is the statistics problem well the
statistics of evaluating experiments or
anything else almost always relies on
independent observations you have a
bunch of iid draws from a population
then you have a theorem about what
happens as n goes to infinity now
there's two problems here one is that
people aren't independent they affect
each other and second the problem is
that what do you mean n goes to infinity
like I hope that had the
graph you know there is no bigger ebay
graph that this is a sample of you know
I have the MIT student graph for my
experiments with Bitcoin you know i'm
not i'm not interested in a hypothetical
universe with a with MIT being three
times as big like I have the MIT graph
so there's a branch of statistical
inference for hypothesis testing that
deals with some of these problems and
it's as it's called it's developed by
Fisher it's called permutation tests or
randomization inference and that method
allows you to do exact I pappases tests
without in going to infinity and without
assuming correlation but it's a very
it's not used all that often because
it's very limited in scope it can only
work for exact to do what's called sharp
null hypotheses so if I think of a sharp
null hypothesis that's our null
hypothesis we're under the null I know
what your outcome would be under any
alternative distribution of other
people's treatment effects so imagine
we're we're a network here if I if my
null is there are no treatment effects
and there are no interaction effects
then under the null hypothesis I can
permute the treatments of all of your
friends but under the null your outcome
doesn't change and because of that I can
generate a dish to statistical
distribution suppose I took my test
statistic was the the average the
difference between treated units and
control units well I could generate the
distribution of that test statistic by
drawing redrawing the treatment
assignments I can imagine re randomizing
you and under the null the the test
statistic um would be if i reran demise
your your your treatment assignment but
that doesn't work for for interesting
hypotheses like network effects because
for example if I'm if my null hypothesis
is there's no peer effects but I want to
allow that a treatment has an effect on
you like you if I change your price
you're allowed to respond then it's not
a sharp null hypothesis anymore because
I don't if I changed your treatment
assignment I don't know what your
outcome would be and so I can't
construct this randomization
distribution so the the novel inside of
our paper is we
figure out how to transform non sharpnel
hypotheses to sharpen all hypotheses if
we basically do it by throwing away some
of the data and defining a new
experiment so i'll just show you a quick
little picture of this so here's a
network the the yellows are treated the
yellow boundaries are treated and so if
I what I want to do is figure out the
effect of friends of friends on me so
what I do instead of studying all the
units in this network I'm going to pick
just two units to study their outcomes
focal you today and focal unit B then in
this network I'm going to say if I want
to test whether friends of friends
matter but I want to allow that you're
being treated matters and I want to
allow that your friend being treated
matters what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take this guy and this guy
those are my focal unit someone's eye
study then I'm going to define what I
call buffer units and that's all the
direct friends of the buffer unit and
I'm going to hold their outcomes fixed
and then I'm going to think about well
okay what's left are friends of friends
people who are friends of friends of my
focal units but aren't friends of any of
my focal units and they aren't focal
units themselves these are auxiliary
units I'm going to then think that these
guys I'm going to reran demise their
treatment assignments and that's going
to generate a distribution so for each
of my fault my exhilarate going to think
about redrawing their treatment
assignments and under the null that
those redrawing shouldn't affect the
outcomes of my focal units so I can
therefore construct an exact
distribution of the of the the test
statistic which is the test statistic
looks at how am i how outcomes change is
a function of my friends of friends and
so using this i can actually it without
taking asymptotics of a network I can do
valid statistical inference on whether
or not friends of friends matter so this
is kind of a fun thing and any of the
motivation from your working on this was
I wanted to be able to sort of rule out
some complex interactions and if I could
rule out some complex interactions then
possibly i can do my econometrics of my
network and measure and measure things
all right so
that's that's one approach I'll just
mention briefly there's an approach that
I've been working on in practice I
haven't published anything on this yet
but it was it's been worked on by my new
Stamford colleague Johan Uganda and he
was at MSR last year so one thing that
you can do is you can try to divide up a
network into communities they're still
going to be spill overs and then you can
actually randomized not at the
individual level but randomized at the
community level and the interesting
statistical problem posed by this is
that some people are so you and the
reason you do this is you're trying to
approximate the counterfactual of what
would happen if all my sellers were
treated but of course there's going to
be some sellers like this guy who has
about an equal number of friends in a
control community and a treated
community because some people are going
to spill over across communities so even
though i did a randomized experiment
there's actually non random assignment
of individuals to being fully treated or
fully control if you're someone with
lots and lots and lots of friends you
probably have an intermediate number of
friends treated and control well if you
don't have a lot of friends you're more
likely to be fully contained so some
people are getting having all their
friends treated some people are having
none of their trends treated but people
with lots of friends are having an
intermediate number treated so there's a
statistical problem then of how you
analyze this data where you did random
assignment but you don't actually you
have to treat it as if it was an
observational study because the
individuals aren't are not randomly
assigned according to their network
structure to having be fully treated and
fully control so something I'm working
on all right so then another approach is
to is to oh I'm sorry this is just a
summary what we just did so there's two
more approaches that I've been working a
whole lot on in the last few years one
is to try to gain insight from your
short-term test by studying
heterogeneity of effects so I can
basically try to look out and see okay
which advertisers were affected a lot
which advertisers were affected a little
which ones were affected positively
which ones were affected negatively and
then use that to try to understand what
the long-term predictions would be this
is going to be qualitative and
directional rather than exact and then
the thing that will give you exact
answers butts going to require a ton
more
shens is to build a structural model and
try to make a full prediction using a
theoretical model and I think of these
things as compliments you can tell
people a little bit qualitatively and
then show them this more complicated
model i should say though that these
types of more complicated models are not
that successful in practice because
they're not because the computer
scientists and engineers and so on
aren't familiar with them so they're
they're harder to use in practice people
don't like all the assumptions even if
it's better than you know you think well
gosh if you could compare like doing a
user level experiment and using a
complicated model maybe you'd like the
model but that's not how it works in the
real world the one place where these
kinds of models are very successful in
practice is for pricing so any consumer
packaged goods product any company that
does a lot of consumer pricing uses
these kinds of models okay so let's talk
now about heterogeneity of effects so
there's a lot of concerns about so in
general if you want to try to understand
whether a treatment had heterogeneous
effects there's a problem that if you if
you try to kind of look at if you have
lots of covariance you know you could
you could kind of do data mining in the
bad sense of data mining you might look
out and find that okay guy there's I'd
say I did an experiment on a drug
there's guys between ages of 62 and 64
with this perfect this pre-existing
condition and they are have a really
strong positive treatment effect but of
course there's a multiple testing
problem if you keep fishing around for
some group like that eventually you'll
find it and that's valid that's not
valid which is why the FDA prohibits
that it's illegal you have to specify a
pre analysis plan you have to specify in
advance all the heterogeneity are going
to look for now if anybody's from the
machine learning community that seems
crazy like how would you possibly know
if you had hundreds and hundreds of
covariates what all the interactions
between those covariance and her
treatment would be so the goal of my
research here is to be able to use
machine learning techniques to look for
heterogeneity but to get out on the
other side of it valid confidence
intervals so in the a/b testing world
for companies they really look hard at
actually the statistical hypothesis test
like was this significantly beneficial
they're going to actually not even
numbers on us on a scorecard if they're
not statistically significant they don't
want to confuse people so it's very
important to get confidence intervals
out for your estimates and that has not
been the emphasis of the machine
learning literature and so that's why
I'm going to take some very standard
algorithms but be the first one to
actually deliver results on them because
the machine learning literature never
care about this like how can it be that
like hundreds of thousands of papers use
random forest and nobody ever asked if
they were asymptotic Lee normal but
nobody cared and it turns out so and
it's actually pretty hard but that's one
that's one of the things we solved so
we're going to do two different types of
heterogeneity they're related
complimentary what is it we're going to
look for segments or subgroups so that's
going to be based on regression trees or
recursive partitioning what that's going
to do is I'm going to take the data I'm
going to divide it into some groups
maybe like ten groups or five groups the
data is going to tell me and within each
group i'm going to estimate a treatment
effect those are going to be interpreted
they're not the best for prediction but
they're going to be very good for
getting valid standard errors and that
are that are very reliable because I
could have you know 10,000 covariance in
a thousand observations basically know
what's existing statistical method is
going to be able to give you a good
estimate in that kind of environment but
i can still with my method i'm going to
tell you divide the data into three
groups and here are the treatment
effects in each group and i'm going to
get a valid confidence interval and it's
going to be no black box nothing magic
about it very easy to understand so very
usable in an environment where
understandability is important on the
other hand in some cases you want to get
fully personalized predictions generally
there the existing literature for
nonparametric estimation is that gives
you asymptotically normal predictions
would be Colonels and k-nearest
neighbors those algorithms fall apart
with like more than three or four
dimensions they just do very badly and
the problem is that if you have say you
had a hundred dimensions of covariance
you can't be close if you're trying to
be close in 100 dimensions you're not
very close in any so what we want to do
there is bring in on
random forest which is essentially an
adaptive nearest neighbor algorithm but
we want to develop the asymptotic theory
for it so our contributions are opted
we're going to actually change the
existing machine learning methods of
trees and forests to achieve these goals
they don't work unless you change them
and they don't and they don't work well
unless you change them even more we're
going to deal with an issue that there's
no observed ground truth that is if
you're trying to do causal inference
there's no you don't actually know what
the right answer is and our methods are
going to provide valid confidence
intervals without sparsity so this is a
picture of a regression tree and it's
basically you do but you use a tree to
divide the data according to covariates
x1 and x2 and then within each leaf you
make a prediction so this is a picture
of what it looks like in covariates face
x1 and x2 and so within each region
you're going to make a prediction just
based on the average value of your
outcome within the region okay so
they're very easy to interpret this is
in the pure prediction case the
prediction is just an average within a
region so for the Economist in the room
it's like running a regression with
dummy variables for each of these
regions but the data told you which
dummy variables to do the alternative
might be to divide it into deciles by
des iles but then you'd have a hundred
parameters instead of however and
there's seven here so this is this is
actually going to be much better and
then but the problem with this is that I
peaked at the data in order to determine
what these boundaries should be and so
if I had a bunch of high epsilon or low
epsilon guys in this region I'm going to
find that and this estimate is going to
be biased okay so that's the problem
with it so I need to fix that bias if I
want to provide valid confidence
intervals so what I'm going to do this
is the notation for causal effects I'm
going to write down why I of why I is
going to be why I of one if you were
treated why I of 0 otherwise and the
counterfactual treatment effect is why I
of 1 minus y I of 0 you only observe
either why I of 0 or why I of one but
you never observed how I for any
particular unit so what we're going to
do is we're going to change the standard
recursive partitioning algorithms to do
a few different things first of all
we're going to directly estimate
treatments when it's annalise second
we're going to modify our splitting
criteria to focus on tree
and effect heterogeneity in term instead
of predicting outcomes our cross
validation criteria is going to have to
estimate the ground truth we're gonna
have to deal with the fact that I don't
observe the treatment effect for any
individual and we're going to use what
we call honest trees that is we're going
to use one sample to decide how to do
the splits and another sample to
estimate the effects and that's going to
get rid of the bias because I'm when I
estimate the treatment effect i'm not
i'm going to be using a set of
partitions that were determined on an
independent data sample now you might
think oh my gosh I'm throwing away half
my data but my point would be wouldn't
you rather learn something true on half
your data then learn something false on
all of your data and in the big data
setting this is often the the right the
right way to go so here's an example I
did an experiment where I flipped the
first and third positions in for being
searched and what I found is when you
take an algorithmic link from the first
to the third position you lose lose
thirteen point six percentage points of
quick three rate so what this looks like
when I then go and see if this is
heterogeneous is I get this tree with a
neat with each leaf of the tree I'm
going to get a different average
treatment effect a different standard
error okay and these standard errors are
going to be valid again because I split
my sample so I'm going to find that for
some queries there's no treatment effect
these are image celebrity queries where
people didn't really care about the
algorithmic results and for others I
give very strong treatment effects like
informational queries where the ranking
matters a lot then what I look at and
see is I see how much does it the bias
matter so what if I estimate my effects
in the same data that I use to make my
splits versus when I'm honest and I use
a new sample so it's a little hard to
see from the table of numbers that my
meme was negative point 136 and so here
are the ones in red or ones where you
get a more extreme result in the
training sample kind of amazing is get a
couple hundred thousand observations
here but yet there's and there's only
like twenty odd leaves but you still get
a substantial bias so the bias doesn't
go away with big data you because you
basically what my my tree is so good at
finding little clusters of guys that
have unusually large or unusually small
treatment effects that you still get a
bias
what if i want personalized predictions
well there's something called the random
forest which is super popular it works
really well in practice it's a predictor
and it's bit what it basically does is
it takes a whole bunch of different
trees and averages them up it also
builds very deep trees so it tries to
make the leaves really tiny so you can
you can each tree differs because your
sub sampling the training set we can
think of this as an adaptive nearest
neighbor algorithm each tree is going
through and splitting on covariance
finding covariates that are important
for heterogeneous treatment effects and
then it's going to figure out who to
like who are the neighbors that are
actually relevant for heterogeneous
treatment effects and it's not going to
try to match you on covariance that
aren't important so if you have a
thousand covariates it's very important
to find the ten covariates that matter
and not try to match on a thousand and
then this algorithm is going to do that
for you um so we developed something
called a causal forest we're going to
use subsampling to create alternative
trees a cool thing now is that there's
actually no cost to being honest because
I was subsampling anyways so I take one
subsample to build the build the leaves
another subsample to do my estimates I
can use different sub-samples each time
so I use all my data but I get rid of
the bias and so out of that what we're
going to do is we're going to have these
causal forests that estimate
heterogeneous treatment effects so if I
if you show me your vector of covariance
i can predict your personalized
treatment effect so these results we're
going to have a central limit theorem
our first asymptotic normality results
out there for random forests and so one
reason i said before nobody cared so not
a lot of people were working on this but
the the way the standard algorithm
that's built into our this was false the
results are not asymptotically normal
the reason is that a bias dominated the
bias is too big but they're good for
mean squared error but they're not good
for asymptotic normality but making them
honest among other things gets me
asymptotic normality it makes the bias
go to zero fast enough if you want
something to be asymptotically normal
and centered on zero the bias has to go
to zero fast enough it doesn't just have
to be consistent the bias has to go fast
enough and so we do that with our
honesty and then we can get causal
confidence in
rules for causal effects so here's just
a picture we're comparing two k-nearest
neighbors because k-nearest neighbours
is something we're asymptotic normality
can in principle works this is the truth
this is our estimates that the colors
are the treatment effects this is K and
n KN in as much messier because it
doesn't know which neighbors are
important to match too we're actually
better in terms of both bias and
variance then came in and if you go up
to like 20 covariance K&N falls apart
because it's just not finding which
neighbors are important while we kind of
hang in there so so basically with these
methods you can get personalized
predictions and in principle you can
build them into an experimentation
platform and so that's what a couple of
the big tech firms are working on right
now and I'm collaborating with some of
them to try to take this and into their
platforms what they're going to do is
whenever you run a test will produce the
subgroups that have bigger or smaller
treatment effects but in terms of
predicting long-term effects this still
has a lot of limitations because all I'm
done so far is say who is affected and
then you still have to pair that with a
behavioral model so the last approach
which I won't have time to show you the
details of this joint with Dennis neck
applause and so this approach again as a
sort of the standard econometrics
approach would be to actually assume
profit maximization in our recent work
we specify a set of objectives and we
estimate a Bayesian model that where we
estimate people's the actual preferences
of the advertisers and so then what we
can do is once we have that model if we
run any experiment we can look at the
short-term metrics and we can see how
different types of advertisers are
affected and then we can say all right
well our model is going to tell me if
you were affected this way this is how
we expect you to respond so it's a way
to basically take a short-term
experiment and calculate a new
equilibrium again this is the one that's
I think the most scientifically valid
it's the only one that really
incorporates all the things we know
we're going on in practice but these are
these kinds of models are kind of hard
to sell in the real world and hard to
have influence so I've had mixed success
some successes some
with with trying to get people to adopt
those types of techniques so in some
this is a bunch of different techniques
ranging from cynical theory to machine
learning experimentation and structural
Bayesian models all trying to solve the
same problem which is just to say look
if I changed something in a marketplace
what's going to happen surprisingly hard
problem so I'm happy to take questions
yeah so you thought a lot about making
an experiment to markets and see it you
know and that's a hard enough problem
already I still want to get your
thoughts on suppose you have no specific
experiment that you want to run but you
just want to optimize the entire market
and hopefully you don't want to run too
many tests right so you can't possibly
test every single design can you comment
a little bit about how you would set out
to do that while still trying to do some
kind of experimentation sure so actually
the the paper i have with dennis as well
as some other stuff that i've done and
recently a few other people kind of
economists have gotten excited about as
well is that you can actually learn a
lot about people's preferences even if
you didn't design an experiment for that
purpose so you know if you think about
being or Facebook or Amazon or Google
you know there are changing things
they're changing little things all the
time but every couple of weeks they're
actually making fairly significant
changes that really you know changes in
the quick prediction algorithms changes
it really at the individual level create
quite a bit of shocks so the aggregate
effect might be small but in the
individual level there's a lot of shocks
so if I can see how an advertiser
responds to these shocks even though the
experiment wasn't designed to shock them
then I can still learn about their
preferences and that's what Dennis and I
do we we try to we actually have one
approach where we look at we just sort
of assume that everything that shocks an
advertiser is what we call exhaustion us
and
and see what happens with that but
another approach is closed more
motivated by a white economist called
instrumental variables where we try to
only use the noise and the data that was
induced by an experiment or by what we
know to be a change that was not related
to the advertiser so I know that every
two weeks they there was a big change in
the system then that shocked I can know
the day before the day asked her and I
can see ah this shock raised this
advertisers prices it did these things
to its objective function and then I see
how they respond to that so this is like
reusing existing experiments it's
actually quite a powerful idea because
say Google is running ten thousand
experiments a year they may never do the
experiment we're interested in
scientifically but if we can find a way
to use that variation we can actually
learn a lot about what's happening in
practice so there's a few people
justinrowe has a paper on this I did
something on this a couple years ago
look at with position effects for ads
for example I guess there's another
another issue that probably confront a
lot is a lot of tests going on in
parallel um so can you use the kinds of
methods you've discussed to deal with
interaction effects across experiments
and that sort of test post hoc wait is
that something you've done I haven't
done that I think that it is actually
for the heterogeneity of treatment
effects thing if you wanted to think
about another application like that you
could actually think of like the
covariance as being all the different
experiments you were in exactly yeah so
I that that's been suggested once or
twice but I haven't gotten to that yet
but I think it's an interesting idea um
yeah one of these spaces are competing
firms like let's say sponsored search
and if you do these experiments and you
don't do it at the whole level you do it
at the one person's level then happy
thought have you thought about the
strategic effects of the response of the
other guys once you take it to the large
well so the the work with Dennis and I
have to be honest we have not succeeded
in computing a new equilibrium for the
entire Bing ab platform we haven't tried
that hard because it's more useful in
practice than it is for our academic
paper but in principle if you know
everybody's objectives you can recompute
the equilibrium for the whole system but
that's actually of course
computationally quite hard
there's millions and millions of bids
that are taking place and that actually
gets back to another another I didn't
have time to talk about it but another
reason it's interesting to think about
these these communities and testing
interactions between communities is that
well suppose I use a community detection
algorithm to find pretty you know
isolated communities and then like if I
can reject the hypothesis that these
guys interact with each other then maybe
that motivates a computational algorithm
that ignore certain links and then if I
have a block diagonal type of strategic
matrix that's a much much better thing
to compute then you know a full
equilibrium among zillions of things so
that's I think this is actually some
place again where go public in computer
science journals or more slightly more
practical disciplines as useful because
the kind of attrition tend to not be
very forgiving of approximations for
bizarre historical reasons where it this
is obviously a place where you want to
make approximations and it shouldn't
hurt you so much Ava you're making
approximations I would say all the time
because you don't actually I'm sorry I
don't believe you really know the or can
infer the objective function of the user
and then in fact even a format on which
you put the upd function is a particular
form and I think we like eucalyptus and
more complex than that these economists
are a little strange and I've come to
you know as you step outside your
discipline you know you you appreciate
more the weirdness of each discipline so
we we will you know make a certain
there's certain kinds of assumptions
we're happy to make and then we stick to
them like this is our functional form
and they profit maximize and even this
is normal and we're all happy with that
but like we can't have an approximate
equilibrium that would be bad bad bad
you know and it's obviously stupid but
these are our conventions yeah can you
say anything about what huh like your
collusions me
if you think into effect that you don't
actually know you don't exactly know it
is hopefully going to be not asserting
exactly they yes so I would say that we
have there's a lot of conventions that
we have for evaluating empirical work
and evaluating its robustness but and
it's a lot of it is arguing and
defending and you know so we're not
super systematic with that and I think
that's actually a criticism I have of
econometrics as a whole is that we're
not systematic at model robustness we're
not systematic at model selection and
that's partly because like we kind of
started from a position where we were
like digging in our heels and defending
these assumptions and then getting exact
results for them so we're not we're not
really able to admit it in a paper
therefore we haven't developed good
formal techniques for doing it follow
following up on an equation if you
cannot complete tickly probably the
advertisers also won't okay so have you
thought about you know going beyond like
like I think it's a very fun prom to
understand Lisa have you thought about
how to go beyond equilibria to some
other types of response yeah well and I
think honestly like in the search
setting in particular they're they're
really not when you talk to them when
you look at the algorithms that are used
by the bidding agents and so on they're
not strategic they're all just best
responding to the current set of
circumstances there none of the the guys
are very strategic so I think that is a
very important thing in some states that
makes things easier because if you just
assume everybody's kind of doing these
is some iterative best responses that
might be a better way and a more
realistic way because everybody it's
likely these things everybody's using
these bidding agents and then the
bidding agents are competing against
each other and if we know those bidding
agents aren't factoring in certain
things then why should we factor the men
you know in our computations so again
though I think if we were writing in
that direction luckily I think Dennis's
now become more of a computer scientist
too so maybe we'll take some of that to
the disciplines that are more open to
those techniques but where we started
when publishing and economics journals
those are harder harder papers to write
not that and emphasize this too much but
is this partly I'm
met a conversation we can have about you
know what the strengths and weaknesses
of different approaches are which also
helps you think about what are open
areas you know the Economist didn't
touch these areas because we have these
religious beliefs and then there's other
things where you know maybe other
disciplines haven't looked at as much
like the causal inference and the
asymptotic normality and machine
learning is something that people just
didn't look at because they weren't
interested